this video is sponsored by facta welcome
everybody to a brand new show you are
watching voice acting 101 which was a
goal that we hit on patreon uh it is a
brand new podcast where i talk to
different actors each month about their
projects approach how they got started
it will include people from tripoli
video games obviously also indie games
but also cartoons and anime if you want
to request guests you can do that on
patreon plus patreon will get completely
ad free versions of the show they also
got this episode i think two weeks early
they got to see the logo production and
have unedited versions i'm really really
excited about this because voice acting
101 and video game writing 101 are both
shows that i knew would not do super
well on youtube they were never going to
get a whole lot of views and so it was
unlikely i'd ever be able to
successfully fund them and pay an editor
and hopefully pay guests pay artists get
merch made all that wonderful stuff
without the support of the people on
patreon and if you didn't already know
my patreon is completely not for profit
any money it makes goes directly back
into making bigger better stuff speaking
of which the next goal is a recurring d
d show so without further delay here is
the first episode of voice acting 101
again just a huge thank you to all the
supporters on patreon who made this
possible i'm so excited and a big thank
you to elias for being my first guest
enjoy elias for anybody who doesn't know
who you are who are you exactly
oh god that's such a complex kind of
hard questions man it's existential um
yes
who who am i
who who am i um
no i'm just i'm uh uh i'm an actor
and a writer and i live in los angeles
i'm presently in toronto though i'm
shooting something
for the next uh five months or four
months here
i'll just jump into a question
immediately because i've always been
curious about this but i've never
actually asked anyone why does
everything shoot in canada
why does nothing actually shoot in la
what why was that the most frustrating
thing yeah it's you moved down to l.a i
did the same i'm from here i'm not from
toronto but i'm from montreal
and uh i moved to toronto a while ago
and all these shows came up and
i did a bunch of them which helped me
build my resume and then i moved down to
la and everything i get shoots in canada
in toronto or vancouver why i've been to
new york a few times well the the the
reason the real reason is just economics
it's just taxes it's taxes it's the
dollars 20 less
so uh
and that that also fluctuates
um usually for the better for the us
dollar yeah um
and uh yeah you know that we
just trying i'm trying to i was about to
give an example and then that would give
away what i was working on
which i can't do i will let me do that
but uh there's a bunch of big studios
here and they're all
you know 75 to 80 cents on the dollar
right there you save a bunch of money
then the the government gives a lot of
tax breaks in vancouver and toronto
absolutely did you ever shoot anything
in l.a
i shot you know i did a bunch of
procedurals not like a criminal minds
yeah you shot in l.a which was great i'm
like oh my god i just gotta go you just
get to go to burbank yeah
but uh
most of the stuff i've done has been
either here in canada
in atlanta or in
william new york
but those are the procedurals that take
place in new york that i went and did
those type of shows yeah i feel like
that you can't people try to make things
look like it's new york when it's not
but i feel like you can usually tell
what happens here a lot they try to do
toronto like new york and it never works
i watched a movie recently that was
clearly british but they were trying to
say it was
i think brooklyn
yeah but then you see like a bin outside
and you're like
that's the uk
that's freaking out
stanley kubrick refuses to let or
refused rather to leave uh uh london so
when he did eyes shut they they changed
all the uh
london streets to look like new york it
works to an extent
never wanted to get on a plane respect
dude respect um
back to you
so i feel like my audience probably
knows you from your pretty lengthy
contribution to video games you've been
in assassin's creed uh
adam jensen is obviously a huge one deus
ex um you've done call of duty death
trending i feel like you've you've done
a lot of video games yeah but you're
also a screen actor
and you've done animation
i feel like you're a really good person
to ask how much do those mediums
actually vary in terms of your skill set
like would you consider them to be
completely different jobs or is it
transferable
oh it's completely transferable because
an actor just comes from the same place
no matter what the medium is do you
think that there would be actors who
wouldn't be able to do all yes but it's
a learned skill you can learn it if you
have the like if you what i'm trying to
say is what you
how you approach a script as an actor
should always come from the same place
right i'm sure you know this the what is
it your character wants what is he or
she trying to achieve what are they
trying to what what do they want out of
this
uh how do they want how do they get it
and then you break that down from the
whole story to uh literally to the scene
to the moment you know like what do i
want right now
and that doesn't change no matter what
the medium is what about video games
where they don't give you the whole
story
well
see this is the thing now so this gets
comp complicated but like when i was
starting out in video games
i wouldn't have the
i i would probably not ask
but now i'll be like guys i'm not doing
this unless you tell me
exactly where what is going on
but i'm not talking about look i did
call of duty right that was seven days
of me with a russian accent basically
just doing things like grenade get down
back down like
you don't really need the motivation
there you're just playing what's the
feel about the grenade yeah exactly
it's basically like you hit it's
technical right you hit the different
levels of uh how far you threw the
grenade or how loud you have to be or if
you're on columns that kind of tech
stuff you learn
but
you know like in any other medium in in
if it's a game if it's an animation it's
on camera and i screw up doing stage
work
it's all exactly the same thing it's
just
the techniques are different
and to
to go back to what you said
i have been because i do a lot of voice
directing too
and i have noticed
that like on a big game that hires a
screen actor who had never done
voiceover before
it's a process to get them
to where they have to get to as um
but that's again it's a technicality the
ability to
respond to somebody right i feel like
that's got to be pretty difficult that's
a new that's yeah but
yes yes
but that's an animation too like in
blood of zeus i never i worked with one
person
and
you know the rest of the time i'm by
myself yeah and these are like emotional
scenes with other actors so i'm always
hoping that i come in second so i go can
i hear what that actor did so i can
bounce off him yeah but
even that sometimes like i can't just
i'm the one setting the ground some
sometimes so it's not something you can
just run into and do all of them but
yeah i guess if you have the foundations
of acting you can pick up each of them
they are just yeah and then you learn a
little techniques like i've taught i've
taught actors who are only voice over
to get on their feet and do performance
capture which is completely different
worlds
uh and a lot of them have trouble you
know because they're so used to just
standing there giving their performance
a lot of them have trouble getting on
their feet so what do i do with my hands
and you can unlearn it's just unlearning
you know your whatever it is that you do
as an actor because trust me if you're a
voice actor you're being expressive in
the booth you just don't realize it
a lot of times or you're doing the right
thing
uh in terms of a performance you just
got to figure out how to get it on your
feet and vice versa if you're an actor
who's only doing on camera and then you
get in a phone that phone booth
feels like a phone booth same thing so
you're like how do you how do you get
the performance out
uh
but not really but you're only using
your voice but you're not really only
using your voice as you know yeah it's
like it's so it's again it's all just
technique and once you learn the
technique as long as you're a good actor
you can do it you'll figure it out it
makes sense it is time to hear a word
from our sponsor facta as someone who
works
way too much
i sometimes think factor is the reason
i'm still able to eat dinner if you
didn't already know facta is a prepared
meal delivery service that provides
fully cooked healthy meals made by real
chefs that are ready to eat in minutes
it completely takes the guesswork out of
what to make for breakfast lunch or
dinner and even offers meals for those
looking to follow keto low calorie or
vegan and vegetarian lifestyle it can do
that while helping you maintain your
fitness goals a lot of like very fast
easy microwavable food can be really bad
for you factor believes that fitness
starts with food and they can help you
achieve your fitness goals through
nutritious purposeful eating they have
ingredients with integrity and are
dietitian approved it's also like when
we're talking about food that we can eat
quickly which again i find so helpful
for my personal lifestyle factor is
easier and faster than like ordering
takeout meals are pre-prepared and ready
to eat in two minutes or less and meal
plans offer variety with a rotating
weekly menu of over 27 meal options and
33 add-ons like smoothies keto shakes
desserts and more so it's fast it's
healthy it's really really really easy
to get started and i think kind of
de-stresses your day in a lot of ways
when you don't also have to factor in oh
what am i gonna eat when am i gonna make
this food do i need to buy these
groceries so use my link or go to
go.factor75.com and use code pog alana
130 for 130
off across six boxes thank you to fact
of sponsoring the video now back to the
video is there one that you find to be
the hardest
i guess you've been doing it for such a
long time now that it's like putting on
a different pair of shoes
yeah that's really that's a really good
analogy actually it's like it's just a
different pair of shoes and you just i
mean the hardest physically is always
going to be on camera because you get up
it's five or six you get there and then
you work until seven or eight pm and
they do it again and again and again
you're there
15 16 hours a day
so that's the most demanding yeah
uh the the best is voice over jobs
because like four hours yeah yeah you
get water all the time nobody stops you
from doing anything you can just retake
things a hundred times and nobody else
is takes ruined yeah living the dream
but you see the great thing is like i
love performance capture because it's a
mix of the two
because i don't have to worry when
you're doing performance caps you don't
have to worry about your lighting or you
have to worry about your mark to a
degree but not really like hitting the
mark on the floor you have to worry
about your hair don't worry about
blocking another actor's light he
doesn't worry about any of that stuff
uh
but you're on your feet doing a full
like physical performance so i really
like doing performance capture the most
recently released thing that i heard
your voice in slash saw you in would
have been as dusk false which i played
so recently that it's almost weird to
jump on this zoom call like it's like
two days apart um
that is obviously a very uniquely
presented video game was that
performance capturing was that pictures
how did they do that
it's actually it's funny because i'll
get people who haven't seen me on screen
and know me from mostly my voice
and they're like hey you gained a lot of
weight for that role like no dude that's
not me
it's not me that's a guy called oliver
britton he's up there
in uh i think he was in france or london
oh it's a completely different okay well
like i feel like they have a little bit
of your likeness but yes it does not a
hundred percent like this at all
no way completely this other actor wow
it's a coincidence that maybe we look
somewhat alike i mean i guess that makes
you a better person
yeah no way
okay so you did the vo and then it was a
different actor but do you i guess i it
looks like they took pictures i have no
idea how they did that but i had they
filmed it they definitely filmed it like
a film but then they took it and turned
it into because i don't even think
i might be speaking incorrectly here but
i don't even think he speaks english
without an accent they just really liked
his look
i could be wrong i could be wrong
uh but he really likes his look and then
they had already filmed a bunch when
they hired me
uh
and i just came on and um
i i just did the voice over stuff which
i guess is very easy for a game where a
lot of it stills
yeah but a lot of it i didn't even see
like i couldn't there were a lot of
animatics and stuff not really uh
not really
ah there was a few that i saw the actual
not finished but almost finished kind of
scenes or cut scenes or whatever but
for the most part i didn't see anything
it was just doing it like like like an
animated series or uh
or a game more like a
you know what it was more like more like
a radio drama that's what it felt like
because it was again i was working by
myself which sucked
but uh
and again this was during coverage i was
doing most of it just from my my house
um
and
yeah there was some where like oh oh you
got the little girl she recorded these
lines already great can i hear them and
then i tried to bounce off of that but
majority of it was just me recording it
i've done it
little bits of pieces of voice acting
and yeah um i'm not very good you know
getting there learning but uh the one
that always gets me is when like
whoever's on the other side of the booth
is the person to read you the line
they do their best
and then when i've had some of those
experiences and then later i hear the
other actor actually reading the line
and i'm like man i wish i hadn't heard
that yeah yeah
it's funny because i've been voice
directing recently over the past year
and um
one of the things that the every actor i
work with loves is that
i'm an actor
so i'm always trying to give them
exactly what they would get if i was
performing that other
character and they tend to like it but
oftentimes i'll have to perform things
that are
not in my wheelhouse yeah so they're
going to get a better performance from
you like a little actor
yeah like things like that what's that
shift been like uh from you obviously
going from voice acting to now voice
directing what's that what's that been
like it's not much of a shift in the
sense that i i used to coach actors like
beginning actors i used to coach actors
a lot so not that it's coaching actors
but it's just i i understand
the way actors minds work and i think
the reason i keep getting hired
is because the actors that i work with
say stuff like
he get he gets he gets it like he
understands how to get me to a certain
place if i'm not getting there i imagine
directing is probably a very hard thing
to do without acting experience because
i think that i've had some
poor
direction and
like i i had one that i was telling
another actor about that i was like
yeah i couldn't do this and the actor
was like what did they say and i was
like they just kept telling me to do
more
like the feedback i got was like you
just need to be more intense and i was
like i don't know what that means when i
think i'm already at 100 and that was a
director who did not have acting
experience and i feel like that the
if you don't know where you would find
it in yourself it's probably pretty hard
to give somebody else advice on
yeah that's a good point i i i give that
direction a lot actually because i'm
if you watch any of my work i'm i tend
to be like a really subtle type of actor
like i want to be realistic and subtle
and
most games are kind of leaning that way
but occasionally i'll get like i was uh
this past whole year i've been directing
a game out of china and they it's just
like the english version of the chinese
game right
and they
are on the call the zoom call i just do
this basically when i'm directing it's
just this
uh and then my script and stuff like
that but they are on the call and
they're always like can you be bigger
and bigger
that key seems to be the note that i get
a lot like he'd be bigger or more scared
or more and i have to i always use the
same as you say oh dude i get it you're
being realistic that's what i like to
but on this game we need to exaggerate
it so let's keep exaggerating yeah and
then i'll i'll find it and then i'll
tell you that's our zone
and then un invariably an actor will
drop back down to what he or she what
they're comfortable with is probably
what they're comfortable with yeah that
you can feel ridiculous
yeah so i guess um you're a great person
to ask like what do you feel like is the
biggest piece of advice that you have
for new actors or people who want to get
started in voice acting what do you
think is the the one thing that can help
them the most
well the thing about voice acting in
particular
is that it's not about
silly voices
it's um
i could do a million silly voices you
know what i i work most as
the guy who sounds like this
i um i
you know i have a couple of characters
that i i voice there are you know
they're different kind of
like we have friends who
just do the crazy cool voices but even
those guys are
are actors
uh who are basing their crazy cool
voices you know real performance
um that's what it is it's not about
being able to do impressions and being
able to do voices it's about being able
to find the realism even if you're
playing like dark wing duck or something
like it's like a
it's a it's
find the acting in it as opposed to
being
uh
just crazy that would be my first piece
of advice is just make sure you're a
good actor
um every actor gives this one piece of
thing and i'm the only actor i think who
says
what i'm about to say
let's go hot takes baby let's do it it's
my hot take on being an actor and i
think it's not just being an actor it's
being anything and i use this example
it's like i love
comic books and i love storyboards and i
can't draw a circle like it's i'm
terrible neither i i could train for
years
but i do not have the innate talent
to be a comic book artist i would be a
fake comic book artist i would be a
trained
fake comic brother and interesting there
are people out there who have the innate
talent
who deserve it more than i would if you
understand what i'm saying yeah
that's i don't know that i agree with
you but but yeah it's okay okay but
that's what i feel about acting too
like you have to just know if you're
good at it and if you're good at it
you'll work
then you get you learn all the
techniques and you learn all that stuff
which comes back to what i was saying
it's like the techniques for being a
voice actor being an on-camera actor
being uh so you're suggesting you're
talking about talent effectively right
talent yeah i guess you know if you can
do it it's not super dissimilar to a
piece of advice that i often give new
writers is
people who are like oh i want to write
video games or i want to write game
reviews or whatever
and it feels like a weird piece of
advice but i always say we have to be a
writer first a lot of people think they
want to write game reviews because they
think they want to write game reviews
i'm like but do you have any history of
writing have you ever written anything
else do you write in your spare time is
that a thing you do and usually the
answer is no
um people just think that's the job that
they want but it's not actually
something they're passionate about
and i feel like that's probably a pretty
similar point of like you do have to
really embody the thing
especially when it's something that can
be really grueling and really take your
whole personality like acting does
it can take your whole life um you
really have to feel it and not you can
it isn't necessarily something to learn
from a book yeah that's that's what
essentially what i'm trying to say it's
like
the example i like to give also is like
out of
you know i went to theater school
and there's like 30 of us because they
accepted everybody
and by the end
three of us make a living as an actor i
think like two of us make a living as an
actor and it's not because
uh like we're
this is gonna sound it's kind of
counterintuitive what i'm saying but
it's like because we just know
we just have that innate ability i look
at it like carpentry too it's like the
same thing it's like i have the i don't
i cannot build anything
i it will fall apart or it will look
terrible no matter how much training i
have i'm not gonna be a beautiful
architect can't do it
and um
i think it's probably the same in in
writing i bet you i bet you you can look
at a new writer who's never written
anything and you look at it and go and i
mean you specifically you could look it
in and go
this has potential this writer
has potential
i'm mental writers and that is
definitely a thing yeah right there so
you can see and then you can look at one
and go i don't know if this person well
i take submissions for it right so right
and it is definitely a thing where i
i'll read 500 and then i go this one and
it's very clear like this one has it
like 100 percent and you can tell and
that's what i'm saying i wish i could
give people an actionable piece of
feedback
that's the thing right you can
actors they're bad actors that work
sure right yeah for sure
but they are bad writers that work too
100 yeah that's damn sure but um but
there's a shelf life there
so all i'm trying to say is that if you
want to do something like voice acting
or writing or acting in general or
anything that's in the arts just know
what it is you're good at
and
do that it's time for another ad break
and this time i wanted to talk about the
recurring dnd show a tabletop
role-playing show that i am currently
working on pre-production for that is
being funded by patreon i mentioned this
at the start of the show and i've
mentioned it a couple of other times but
clearly not enough because every time i
mention it there are so many people
saying oh my god this sounds amazing i
hadn't heard about this we are 74
complete towards our goal of making a
recurring d show featuring cameos and
crossovers from multiple across my
various podcasts i have four permanent
role players who will be joining me and
i have already announced to rahul coley
and jacob fullerton so the vibes will
definitely be akin to idiots and abroad
which sadly got cancelled and it is dark
souls themed i expect it to be very
funny and i'm also planning to get extra
creative with it maybe we have someone
make music for an episode we have
someone do art for an episode i think
it's going to be super fun but my plans
for it are also very costly so if you
want to help out check out the link in
the description
patreon.com and you'll be up to date on
the show you'll get the first episode
before everybody else you get rough cuts
and unedited cuts and you are helping to
support content that definitely uh does
not do very well on youtube thank you
for watching now back to the podcast
yeah for the people who haven't really
feel like they have it they're very
passionate about it um something they've
always wanted to do they have that
talent what do they do
how do they start working
so the the
you know two or three years ago i would
have said move to l.a move to new york
uh go to toronto if you're in canada go
to vancouver if you're in canada that's
kind of changing now though after covid
i haven't left my house in two years for
work unless
they've flown me up somewhere but even
this job which is a big job that i'm on
for months i didn't go to an audition or
meet anybody i just did everything from
my house
uh and then i got it and they flew me
here so it's like
for voice actors now
get make yourself a demo with a
professional sound
so if you're good at tech stuff and you
can you have a really good mic like you
do
you could be you can make yourself your
own demo
at home uh but what i would do is what i
did
15 years ago
i went to a sound studio and i was
living in vancouver at the time
and i said i need i need a demo
um a commercial demo and a
and a cartoon or an animation demo
and he's like okay here's a bunch of
commercial scripts
and uh what do you want to do for your
animation then i just wrote a bunch of
stuff for voices that i was good at you
know what i mean
and then i went to the studio i think i
paid them
like 600 bucks it's probably more now
yeah but uh
and they made me the demo is
professional sounding
right not just from your phone or at
home like unless you're really good at
this tech stuff get a professional
sounding demo and then just shop it
around to agents essentially
um
and in the meantime
i would definitely take classes if
they're around in your area for two
reasons one it's good obviously it's
good to take classes it's good to learn
but also as i take classes still just to
keep you know sharp yeah it's awesome
yeah
uh
but
those people will know agents and people
that should listen to your demo true
things like that great way to know if
yeah if you're in la there's a bunch of
of
classes that you could take and then
they'll help you build a demo
well at this point there are online
classes too like you can find online
classes
even make that through zoom if you don't
live in la so it's a little bit more
accessible as well 100 and that was my
other thing i was going to say is
you don't need to live
there anymore as long as i think you
still should get
an agent that is new york or la based
but i don't
i don't know that you need to live there
anymore probably not which is great it's
more accessible yeah so it's much more
accessible so there's going to be like
10 in 10 years gonna be 10 times the
competition that's true
but uh
but you once you have that demo and uh
if it's good even if it's decent just to
get you the auditions
and then
a really good piece of advice i heard
when i moved down to la
one of the animation directors said
i will get your audition and i won't
cast you for about 10 or 20 auditions
that i get from you just to hear how
you know how good you are through the
like they never have any texture they
have their group of people that they
usually know
and they cast out of that and then
eventually you start cracking into that
group
and um
it's tough it's hard i mean acting is
a lot of uh rejection and i'm saying
this
tangentially like this isn't just from
the actors i know is like oh for sure
it's you putting yourself out there all
the time with something that's very
vulnerable and then never hearing back
even if it took you five hours to do
yeah and just never no response like
it's
brutal
in the recent years of my career
when uh to be fair this is
at a point in my career where i'm making
enough money and i'm
working enough on other things but i
just did one yesterday i had an audition
for this big movie i did one take and i
sent it
and i'm just like no because it's
amazing i'm just like i'm not going to
give
so much energy to it yeah because i
learned after
15 years of doing this that that exact
thing i used to spend five hours on that
they watch one second right like they
know straight away they don't watch the
whole performance they know straight
away if you're right or not exactly yeah
and then when you get into the callback
phase then i would put more work into it
and make sure that you know okay what
did they what were their notes and make
sure you do all that but those first few
auditions like for voice auditions man
i'm like knocking them off so fast
i'm just sending them in
uh because yeah because it's just the
way you sound like they just hear it and
they go nope and and what's the point in
investing so much time in it
that makes sense also again this comes
back to you again
but i know that i'm good at these things
sure there are things that i'm not good
at like there are
there are things on camera particularly
i told my agent when i moved down here
like don't send me for uh
best buddies like i don't play that
character
don't
um i can't do emotional women and i get
emotional woman a lot as a request and i
keep being like i'm not that [ __ ] i
can't do it they i but you know what it
is you that yeah you know what it is
that you give me sassy sarcastic girl
daria type i got you but the minute that
you give me emotional woman who has to
cry about something i'm gonna be [ __ ]
awful
and then it's a waste of everybody's
time 100
yeah so that's that's what i've learned
recently again much like earlier
10 years ago i was like okay i need to
spend five hours making sure this
audition is perfect
maybe i should have back then but
now i'm like yeah maybe you need more
time yeah it makes sense that's wisdom
that's growing that's learning and
that's why your input is valuable to
people here um
for all the conversations we're having
right now when you started out like when
slash how did you know it was going to
be a career for you or what was the
point where you were like i'm going to
do this i'm going to make this this my
life
well i was always um
ever since i was a kid it sounds cliche
but ever since i was a kid i saw like
star wars when i was a kid i was like oh
how do i do that but i didn't know what
that was i just i think deep down i just
wanted to be like luke skywalker yeah
i was like how do i how do i do that and
then i remember i was at my uncle's
house um
and he had on
kenneth branagh's henry v
like i can still see it in my memory
i see like the living room and where it
was on and i was like what is this
i was like 14 or 15 or something
and
i didn't understand what was going on
but i was enthralled
with kenneth branagh's performance
derrick jacoby you know he's great you
know i was great actors
and uh
that made me start studying theater
and then once i realized what acting
really is
i went to theater school
which had you know some things that i
took from it but but not that much
i studied uh journalism and
entertainment and i did entertainment
writing and i did not learn that much
from the journalism
it's funny colleges there's a whole
other whole other discussion but yeah
there's not much i took from it but the
experience of it because we did a bunch
of plays yeah that i'm sure like just
seeped in right yeah
and um then the really big my really big
problem with a lot of programs in acting
is they don't tell you what to do once
you graduate yeah like i i knew get
headshots get an agent
but i didn't know about taxes i didn't
know but yeah you know like benefits
benefits i didn't know the like that
site there's life stuff and then i
didn't know
you know like really what a callback was
or what it entailed
i even thought you know the first
audition now especially the first
audition is you and the casting director
and then the casting director will
decide whether
you move on right
especially now it's just the tape and
the casting director yeah so
i would always get really nervous about
the first audition
and cause you'd be like what if the
director sees this and they hate me
forever oh they won't even see all that
kind of stuff yeah
nobody really sat me down and said like
no no she's casting director that if
you're good enough to get kicked up to
the director you're good enough to be
seen by the director you'll be fine you
know that kind of stuff
um
basically i graduated from
from theater school i did a bunch of
theater a really low
like 250 a week type thing nice
um
and then i think i saved up like seven
grand canadian and then i went to new
york
at illegally because i didn't have a
green card it wasn't illegal it's just
you're not allowed staying past six
months and you did
no i kept going back so we're like oh
yeah yeah yeah uh
but uh i was doing off-broadway plays
and
theoretically i shouldn't have been
taking any money yeah you know what i
mean but every dollar went to like
renter so i didn't have any money
uh and then eventually i just ran out
ran out of money literally i had nothing
and i went back and i stayed with my
grandmother in montreal for about a year
and i got myself an agent
uh
i think he came to see a play i did
montreal he's like yeah i'll represent
you and he got me this audition for this
movie called decoys which is a canadian
movie
canadian like sci-fi comedy
and i booked it i booked the audition
and it was like the second lead in this
movie that was going to be in theaters
in canada
and it gave me like
10 grand which at that time was a lot of
money
the most money i've ever seen in my life
and
uh
what i ended up doing essentially so
just to
to reiterate got an agent
got head shots got an audition
book the audition wasn't my first one
obviously i had done 20 auditions at
that point
and then i booked that audition and gave
me 10 grand first thing i did was
use that 10 grand to move to vancouver
because like we were just we were
talking before we started that
everything
was shooting in vancouver yeah
uh and toronto but i wanted to go far
away from home as you do when you're 21.
hey i did the same thing i moved to
california so
so i moved to vancouver and then it was
interesting because i was the lead in
this film and i got to vancouver and
i was auditioning for like one day roles
because it's like i don't care if you're
leading film you have one thing on your
resume yeah like crazy
like you got gotta build like the first
thing i did was one line on smallville
uh just grabbing superman grabbing tom
welling and saying like get me out of
here or save me or something like that
that was all i did after a lead in a
movie so that was a bit of an eagle hit
uh the reality of that field of work i
think yes nobody cares
i'll
tell you what happened after that so
then i um i just kept auditioning and
getting like small role small roles real
started getting bigger but before they
started getting bigger i ran out of
money
that 10 grand didn't last me very long
so i got a job at blockbuster
and
i was stalking
movies that i was in like the movie that
i was in i was like putting it on that's
wild
and i was like
this is the most depressing wow yeah
like my name and my face is on this
movie poster and you're at the
blockbuster putting them in there for
seven bucks an hour yeah
and i was like this is shout out to
blockbuster though we miss you every day
uh
yeah it was dvds i'm not that old it
wasn't vhs
uh
but uh
then i remember
like quitting that job three days later
something i can't do it i'll find
something else i'm not
and then a couple of days later i ended
up booking uh
i don't remember the show it was like a
week on a show
um
and you know
you make
you know for a week you make like five
grand and then you're like okay am i
stretching that's fine yeah
and then eventually you
are just a terrifying thing about acting
is you never know when you're going to
work again yeah i mean look for all
intents and purposes when i get home
after this big game this could be your
last job my last job ever i think you'll
be all right but like that it really is
like you're right that it it's kind of
unfortunate that you know once you've
gotten to the point where you're making
money from it more than the
one percent or whatever um even if it's
very little
you don't get taught at any point those
life skills you don't get taught hey
you're not gonna make a million dollars
in your first year as an actor i know
that you think you are but you're not
you making you're getting a lead role
doesn't mean that you've automatically
got it made and yeah taxes are a
nightmare like it almost feels like it
should be a part of those taxes yeah
it's it's terrifying like it's so
difficult to approach especially when
you move out home you're like i nobody
told me how to do any of this yeah it
almost feels like it should be a part of
some of those courses to teach you
really really how to survive
wrong yeah but it's it's tough but but
you know
that's the cliche right the hills and
the valleys and the hills
but the hills are great when they're
when they're good when you can just stay
up there for
you know six months a year yeah like
it's it's amazing and i actually
experienced i was i've been working as
an actor and doing pretty much nothing
else for
probably
12 years now
like the first three years are pretty
rough and then 10 12 years i've been
just did you have a point where you
i love asking people this question
because everyone has pretty much the
same answer but a different spin on it
did you have a point where you were like
okay i'm good i made it
yes and it was only recently it was
really only recently i was doing an
interview like uh like this it wasn't a
podcast or something
i don't know it doesn't matter i was
doing an interview and somebody said so
what do you want to accomplish in your
career and i was about to come up and
shoot what i'm shooting here and i was
like
kind of
kind of doing it thing you're doing yeah
yeah it's like i'm doing this vid this
amazing video game and then i'm doing
this amazing animated series and then
i'm leaving for six months to do a
really cool show
it's like if i just can keep this up
that's the dream yeah can i just just
work support a family
pretty much yeah i got two kids yeah
what uh
because it seems like from the outside
perspective that it's huge did did deus
ex have a big
impact on your life where you were at
that point in your career like did was
that a big thing
it did um but
was that 2010
it was 2008 when the first one came out
right
and then no 2000 to 2008 when i started
on it i think human revolution
was 2011
okay that was close
technically neither of us right
yeah that's true
i started in 2008 on that yeah that
makes sense and then um
yeah what happened with that that was
interesting was that the um
the character the game is great
the game is really good and so
it supported this but the character kind
of got jumped on into like this pantheon
of
video games basically a meme
yeah like got jumped up into this weird
kind of like suddenly uh there's you
know when you see like video games you
see the guy from halo and the witch and
that adam jensen's up there yeah that's
weird that happened quick so i kind of
ran with it and i started like a twitter
account started following the comic-con
people
and things like that which is other good
things you should learn as an actor it's
blatant self-promotion is actually
really good official um
and so what what happened was
uh the only thing that really came of it
was that i started getting a bit of a
cult following so i would use that
called following
to say hey comic-con people from
wherever whatever city like bring me to
your
to your city that makes sense and then
you know i wouldn't get paid a like a
huge amount of money or anything but i
would
go and i would meet other people in
games like you and other people i just
constantly meet other people and
over the years what i realized what had
happened
and i'll just give an example of this
like i'm playing the penguin in gotham
nights
it's coming out at the end of
october or something i didn't audition
for that it's just everybody on gotham
knights worked on deus ex oh no way at
one point huh and something like well
eliza is a good actor he's going to show
up on time he's going to get he'll get
it done reputation they actually they
actually called me they're like uh yeah
we want you to play the penguin i was
like great and then they hung up i'm
like
i don't even know how i'm gonna
that's the other thing actors do all the
time it's like oh yeah yeah i can do it
i could do it right horseback
[Laughter]
oh my god how am i gonna do it i think
that's also
a thing that from my perspective which
would be a lot narrower than yours
i feel like the games industry does a
lot the games industry goes we should
just ask this actor there are often for
roles because the writing process takes
years and years where at least for
triple a um where it's more helpful for
you to have thought of an actor in your
head and then throw an offer out and i
feel like that probably doesn't happen
as much in other writers rooms where the
games industry just often offers things
yeah maybe yeah well the games industry
is is is uh is tight-knit
uh even as a even as a director uh
i ended up
i'm not casting at all i just direct
and i end up like oh you again yeah oh
you okay
but you end up working with these these
same uh same bunch of actors but it's a
good amount and it's getting it's
getting bigger and bigger definitely
yeah so out of things oh go ahead oh i
was gonna say the other thing is
the difference between on camera and
voiceover voiceover including games and
animation
is night and day
in terms of
how great the people are or how not
great how kind the people are
like
on camera is like the doggy dog it's
really rough yeah but voice over
everybody's so great there's no vanity
in it i guess that could kind of come
out maybe that's what it is but
everybody's so great everyone was like
when i moved down here you know people
like jennifer hale and [ __ ] jones and
i love both of them yeah this is one of
my favorite people on the planet [ __ ]
yeah she's the best yeah she jennifer's
also amazing i just don't know
i lived at jennifer's house for a long
time and then
yeah she brought
she left and she's like take my place
and rent it for me no that's awesome
let's do that yeah everyone kind of
knows everyone yeah and [ __ ] you know
when i came down to la she
called her agent so you got to meet this
guy and she
i can't say what it is again because
stupid nd is but [ __ ] and i are on a
game
that i would not have gotten a massive
game that's coming out soon
massive role that i would not have
gotten at all if it wasn't for [ __ ]
and courtney taylor
and jennifer hill they all said well
you've got to hear this guy then i went
in and i auditioned and i booked the
role but i wouldn't even have that
audition yeah
if it wasn't for them yeah reputations
definitely matter a lot in the in the
voice of a world and people will help
each other out yeah um i i watched an
actor uh
a friend tattoo sure i watched him walk
out of a booth once
and see another actor there and lean
into the booth he goes you want him for
the role
after he's like just left for an
audition no way because he knows he's
like yeah like i was saying he knows
what he can do and he's like oh this is
the guy that he didn't say about me but
he said about another actor that's funny
a friend of mine
tells a story about how he went to an
audition once and he went to the
audition with another actor in mind he
was like i'm gonna play it like this guy
this is like who i'm trying to embody
and when he left the room that actor was
sitting behind him
and that actor got the role so it's like
wow you did a really good job of costing
that actually you know exactly who it
should be that's crazy yeah that's funny
yeah um i was going to ask for adam
jensen so yeah
you
you smartly recognize that it got a cult
following like i feel like the most
recent thing that done that that's done
that would have been um lady d
the actress maggie like she was just
like oh i need to make a twitter account
very smart yeah for sure um but does
that mean that adam jensen at the time
like until you until it came out and it
had that cult following
you had no concept of how iconic that
character was going to be no concept
interesting the in fact i don't really
love i don't really love my performance
in the game
in human revolution
because they just said like we want like
a clint eastwood voice
and so i was very very travelling
yeah and and it's pretty much my voice
except i never i never go higher i never
go here i just stay here yeah it's
pretty much my voice
um
but in human revolution that's very kind
of stoic and i would stand up straight
and just everything was i always just do
that i never asked for this yeah i just
just do that over and over again
um
but uh so i don't love the performance
so i didn't know that the game was going
to be and i knew what deus ex was
because i'd played it when i was a kid
on the on the pc in 2000
but then when it came out and it kind of
exploded
even it's funny looking back because
even within that short amount of time
from when we then went and did the dlc
it had already gone so popular and i
played through it all the way and i'm
like oh even my performance in the human
revolution dlc which is
i can't not answer these questions it's
a i'm always like what is it called the
missing link
missing link yeah even i like my
performance better in missing length
than i do in
human revolution because i understood
the character by the time we were doing
the dlc that's super interesting and i
really like
this this kind of leans into performance
capture but
uh in human revolution i'm five almost
five eleven and adam jensen's six three
so in human revolution they got an actor
who was six three to do the body just
the body
and i hated that
and i was like why are you getting
anybody else to do anything with adam
him jesus that's not me
i don't like that
but at the time especially like the
limitations of performance capture there
wasn't even motion literally just
capturing the motion yeah but then when
they asked me to do uh
mankind divided
he's like i'm not doing it unless i can
do the
full performance capture
and i love
love there's still something i don't
like about it but i like mankind divided
my performance in mankind divided way
better the i think the game is not as
strong but my i like the perform my
performance way better because
any time it was a cut scene it was me
performing again
and i knew the character a lot better
for the voiceover performance yeah so i
was a lot more comfortable and um god i
hope we do another one like as busy as
people hope that
happy as i am i really really want uh
i would take like the six months to just
nothing else just sex it's awesome to
hear that what do you think it is about
that character that people um kind of
clung to so much
i don't know i think i think it was
anybody ever ask you like why
ghostbusters is so good
perfect film like you can't but you you
can't recreate that movie no you can't
it's just like trying to get in the box
it's perfect right
there's just lightning in a box and
that's how i felt like jensen
the design was so cool his design from
from the beginning
uh
my vocal print fit him really well
and then the game world was so
interesting and with augments and and
yeah he couldn't have taken off without
those games being as good as they are as
well
but what i'm saying what i'm saying is
like it's not just like the voice that
made him great or it was it was all this
stuff all these people that had to put
into him cohesion
yeah
that worked it was lightning in a bottle
and people really liked it
um
and so like when we did mankind divided
we were just like okay let's just keep
building on on that
but there are whole other issues with
the
with that game yes famously quite
complicated yeah company stuff and yeah
and it was really frustrating being an
actor because you're like guys can we
just
focus on that
yeah can we just make the thing come on
yeah
so yeah if only video games were that
easy
yeah i mean i the property got
sold too
well square sold it to i don't remember
the name of the
company there's like a group it's called
something group it is uh it's so weird
that i keep forgetting what they are
because they own so many things right
now um completely forgotten what it is
but hopefully that means that it won't
be stagnant because square kind of did
have a bunch of properties they weren't
doing stuff with so yeah so i mean
there's no sex but there's you know i i
also um enforce a group
maybe unfortunately or something like
that
and foster group makes it sound evil but
i know
it's something like that
um yeah i don't remember something like
that you're right i'll let it go i'll
let it go i have to let it go
yeah you can find it right now don't
have to google everything
um
the thing is though there's no real
i i'm perfectly
willing to admit that um
it doesn't necessarily mean they're
going to do
uh adam jensen again i hope they do and
i feel like we should finish the story
yeah i think they'd be pretty inclined
to continue
embrace a group that's much better than
enforce a group
so if he is a character that you know
you ended up really enjoying obviously a
lot of people really enjoyed it i'm not
going to ask you to single anyone out
but more i just want to talk about the
experience have you had any characters
that you've ended up being cast as that
you really didn't enjoy playing you
don't have to list the characters what
i'm saying just like what is that like
where does it come from how does it how
does it feel well here's the thing about
starting out as an actor is you take
everything yeah you just take everything
and there have been for some reason on
camera
even in this thing i'm doing now
i just i play bad guys a lot like i play
like guys who are cracked like broken
used to be nice guys now they're broken
i play that all the time we're talking
about the wheelhouse right but you know
what it is you play
and so i told my agents like look this
is what i seem to be booking these
broken down like bad guys
so just submit me for those things and i
don't care because i just want to work
yeah and that's why i kept doing like
shows like fbi and criminal minds and
i when i did a fbi a few months ago and
i remember thinking to myself
i could take this character and put him
in like
three other shows
that i've done
and the same guy
you have a head canon of this dude's
adventures across multiple fbi
um
so um i have played characters that i
don't like that i'm just there for the
work yeah um
but that's the gig that's what it is
it's is you live for the times that you
you get to play something really cool
like like this show like i'm doing now
i'm like so excited about this and or if
dsx would ever come back and there's
another thing i can't talk about that's
that's amazing what i'm doing with [ __ ]
which is amazing really really good game
great character
or blood of zeus which is the netflix
show that i do yeah i love that show i
love that character so um
and the thing with well i think most
actors do this but like once i get a
character that i really like
i do i'm like i'm bugging the producers
like send me the next script going on
are we doing another season what's
happening
uh as opposed to you know these other
shows that i do you don't really follow
up
their work edition well would you agree
with the
the common sentiment of like one for
them one for you
except it's not always that ratio yeah
sometimes it's five for them but i think
that that is like a good you know thing
to openly talk about because acting can
be so romanticized that it is also a job
you are loaning your body out to a
company and you might not like whoever
the character is you might not like the
production like that is a reality if you
want to be successful and do it full
time is it gonna have to do stuff that
you don't really care about that's
really what it is and
and just be
if
if there's ever a piece of advice i
would give actors is
show up on time know your lines
don't be a dick like just be
be fun to work with you don't have to go
there go like hey everybody you just
gotta show up and just don't be mean
yeah be kind
and know that you know you want to keep
working do that
be the guy or the girl and be they who
shows up and says
uh who shows up and they say
this person's got the job done i don't
have to worry about this person first
job i ever did that canadian film every
time i did a take i would like run up to
the director like okay is it okay yeah
and he said to me and this is my first
day ever doing anything professionally
said if i'm not talking to you it was
okay yeah
and then i realized oh okay he has a
million things to worry about it's your
job to make his job as easy as possible
exactly not for you to nag him for
reassurance or validation which has got
to be tough when it's performance yeah
but that is your job as an actress make
the everyone else's jobs as easy as you
possibly can and i think a writer is
very similar it's like it's just it's my
job to make sure that nobody else has to
worry about this part of the thing
that it's done it's not about like them
needing to email me back and be like
this is really well written if they
don't reply
i did it and i didn't ruin someone's day
great
yeah which i i feel like they're editing
all your stuff and you're like oh i have
a million edits that i'll find the next
day either way we'll get it done but i
feel like that's also got to be a pretty
difficult thing about
acting is
again performance is is such a
vulnerable thing
that i feel like it must be really hard
not to seek validation and approval
all the time but it's not worth the time
of a director to reassure every actor
all the time that they're doing a good
job that's got to be tough i still want
it yeah i'm still like
shooting last week and i did a really
cool emotional scene like waiting for
somebody that was good right
yeah but if they don't tell you it means
it was good yeah they're like cut got it
let's move on because they have a
million other things to shoot yeah and
i'm like okay good that means it was you
gotta just self-validate which is like
definitely a skill it takes a lot of us
a long time to learn um then you get you
get your validation later after the show
airs if they uh true
you're all
if your character is cut up to a bunch
of
tiny little scenes like oh maybe i
didn't do it's such a good job
you just gotta wait for the external
validation or to be torn apart could go
either way what a what a great limbo to
live in it's the schrodinger's cat of
anxiety it's great
um so to jump away from you know more
serious topics right now i just wanna
ask you some like quick questions who's
your favorite actor
dead or alive up to you american or
british
you're very i think uh i think the
my favorite actor is probably anthony
hawkins
i just think he is the greatest living
actor right now
if i'm going to differentiate from that
then who who would be the dead pig
orson welles huh but i just love orson
welles yeah or peter o'toole or i think
the greatest american actor alive is
denzel washington he's brilliant um
but i have those are like the like the
icons that i like yeah those are you the
best who's your favorite
different well they're also they're also
kind of like my favorite of the best but
sure but like like anthony hopkins is
i'll watch him
sit there and just think it'll be like
he's the genius yeah
but uh
you know i love guys like like john
goodman's one of my favorite actors and
if you know who andre brauer is i don't
andre brauer is um
reason probably my favorite movie of all
time which is which is glory but he's uh
he was the chief on brooklyn nine-nine
oh yeah okay oh yeah he's awesome yeah
yeah he's like a legendary and yeah
homicide vincent d'onofrio was a great
actor
those are like kind of
because i i look at myself as like a
workaday actor right so i i kind of
relate to those type of guys sure who
are you know
legends but uh
to me
you know i worked with this actor named
david stratham who you would know
if you saw him
he he was nominated for an oscar for
playing uh edgar romero and good night
and good luck oh okay yeah he's in la
confidential and he's
i did a show with him called alphas
and um
it was great i got to work with him for
three months it was amazing
and i asked him he lives in um he lives
in connecticut i believe
and i asked him
i don't i actually didn't really ask him
anything i just paid a lot of attention
to him and i realized that he lives in
connecticut he's 65. he can walk down
the street and nobody's gonna know who
he is the dream
but
everybody in the business
knows who he is preferable and so they
call him and they bring him to where
they want him to work
and that's all i've ever wanted to
accomplish as an actor
so when people do ask me that question
like what is it you want to accomplish
yeah i'm very happy where i am and what
i would want is for somebody to say
oh you want to work with
alike i mean that's a huge
legacy of like what a wonderful thing to
have people routinely say about you
exactly people in the people in the
business that's really all i want i
don't really
i mean i'd like the the money
the crazy famous the fame seems shitty
i've never really got thought about the
fame yeah i've sought out the uh
like to me things like this is just me
though like red carpet things
very i don't like them they like make me
feel weird
i remember doing when i would do theater
my least favorite part was
the bows afterwards
because i feel like beforehand i could i
could lose myself in the character so
it's not me no matter what i did it
wasn't me you bowing is you but it's
also the audience is playing a scripted
role and they're aware of what they have
to do and the whole thing is so
performative from everybody maybe yeah
you're right i should just keep that as
a performance
yeah it's always been like my least
favorite thing i like podcasts actually
because it's just we're just having a
conversation yeah
i don't know that we've actually ever
met but we talked every now and again on
uh
social that's what i said when i asked
you to do this i was like
hey if we know each other enough yeah
it's weird right probably matt i don't
know i think you probably met at a
comic-con i think we probably have
at some point um
but i don't i don't mind talking about
this stuff it's it's cool but i'm sure
you're taking the time yeah the
the fake stuff that's what it is the red
carpet stuff red carpets are weird too
because um
sometimes and this has never happened to
me i've just watched it happen to other
people
you know someone from a news outlet or
whatever will walk up to an actor and
ask them a bunch of questions but you
see on their phone that they don't know
who the person is they're just like what
was it like working with the director
it's this weird like cattle
i don't know something very
uncomfortable about it
first red carpet i ever did
which i i didn't want to do with the
company asked us to go to the premiere
and i was walking down
and uh some
teenage girl was like hey
who are you
hi everyone why am i here yeah it seems
really silly that i'm here i went like
i'm in the movie
i went to a movie premiere for color out
of space
and
yes which i really enjoyed elijah wood
was there
because i think it had something to do
with his production company i don't know
okay um and so we go outside and people
are taking pictures of him and then i
guess somebody in that crowd
knew who i was and so then asked for a
picture of me and i was like sure and
then the mob
half of them chased him down the street
literally he was running and then the
others turned to me because i was a
person that somebody asked for a picture
with and i knew that they had no [ __ ]
idea who i was they just were like well
this person they asked for a picture
with this but they they must be in the
film and i wanted so badly to each of
those people to be like you don't know
who i am but you kind of can't do that
so i'm just like taking some pictures of
people who don't [ __ ] know who i am
yeah it is it is uncomfortable yeah but
of course like people expressing their
appreciation is always going to be nice
and that's always going to be like you
go to a convention and you meet the real
fans and that's always like such a nice
break from the internet right totally
that's a very sweet thing i get
paid i have been getting i was at i was
doing montreal comic con last couple
weeks ago
and um it's like fan fan fan like really
cool and then there's somebody who
inevitably goes i'll take one of those
one of those one of those ones
i'm like signing all these things he has
no idea who i am you're just going to go
and sell sell them yeah i learned
recently that um if they give you a
whiteboard and ask you to sign it it's
for sales
because it happened to me at again at a
friend's red carpet i was just standing
in a corner and somebody asked me to
sign something and it's a whiteboard and
a blue pen
and that means they're going to transfer
your signature onto a picture of you
when you get home and then sell it
yeah it's like damn it's so [ __ ]
that's a whole industry it's so crafty
yeah people got to make money i guess in
the end yeah that's exactly what i was
about to say and yet it's just people
trying to make a living totally you
gotta do it somehow it's hard out here
some of us work at blockbuster
i worked at mcdonald's for years i know
that's so funny did anybody ever come up
to you with your own movie
no thank god in three days that would
have been great though although i do
have a redemption story that whereas i
got fire i used to work at a movie
theater
and uh i got fired
because i missed too many shifts but the
last shift that i missed was to go to an
audition
for a movie
and then i got that really hell yeah and
the movie played at the theater hell
yeah
did you go back yeah my name was on the
poster and everything no way that's
something like oh my god look at you i
didn't like i didn't go like this
that's amazing though
fire question before i let you go don't
wanna keep it too much longer so you
mentioned obviously the luke skywalker
being uh you know something that
potentially you looked up to that
inspired you and i
i feel like people your age than
the 20 years surrounding a lot of people
luke skywalker really did it for them i
don't think you're alone on that one but
is there any like outside of that a
singular performance that you found to
be extremely
inspiring something that you often think
about
yeah i mean i mentioned orson
welles uh
citizen kane for me is like
again these are things i've realized
discovered as i was older yeah you know
i i didn't know what kenneth branagh's
name in the fifth was when i wanted to
be an actor but then once i discovered
and you start you know i just love
warsaw so much and then orson welles did
the radio plays and he was a big voice
actor
so i was a director as well wasn't he he
directed citizen kane he wrote directly
of course he did of course he did yeah
i know that he started out as an actor
yeah 285 and he didn't know what he was
doing and that's how it turned out so
good is because he didn't play by any of
the rules he was just like yeah he said
uh he i love this story this kind of
harkens back to what we were talking
about about
you know going to school and stuff like
that he said that he just happened
well yeah most definitely he just had it
but he went to he was doing the uh the
film and the reason the move or
citizen kane is so grandiose in these
these amazing shots is because he came
from theater so he didn't know that you
can't do it
and nobody told him you can't do it this
way
so he would be like well i want this
angle and they couldn't do it so he
would like cut a hole in the floor to
get the camera as a roll result became
like the father of modern cinema
effectively
yeah and his cinematographer also was
really like do what you got to do i'll
i'll help you i love that though like i
love the idea of and again i had just
disconnected austin wells from directing
in my head for whatever stupid reason i
i love the idea of
somebody having an eye for something in
a vision and a passion and obviously a
team is super important who also believe
in them
but that they haven't been told what
they can and can't do so they just make
magic like what a cool story this is
what's the best yeah that's why i've
always loved arsenal's but i have like
so many you know got so many
performances that i'm like
like
glory
to me is one of the best movies you've
seen gloria it's with denzel washington
civil war it's a civil war movie it's
about the first
uh black regiment
in the union in the civil war
it's phenomenal he's
he won an oscar for it denzel one it's
that it's like a performance that i
watch
over and over and over again and like
things like uh i'm a giant star trek fan
and uh
star trek two to me the one with khan
the wrath of khan to me is one of the
greatest action science fiction movies
ever or science fiction adventure movies
ever and
for all the flack that shatner gets he's
incredible and then he is like
legitimately really really good yeah
and i'll watch those scenes and to me
the best acting school even though i
went to school for three years is just
watching
whatever relates to you whatever you
relate to
and repeating it
like i'll turn off a movie after i watch
it i'm going to do that scene that's
interesting
yeah and then i try to
and then i what i do is i mimic it and
then i try to say
how would i do it
and you want to know when i knew i was
good this is a true story i knew i was
good when i watched
hopkins do something
and
i got the script
and
i
i only watched it once and then i got a
script and i did it and i i did it like
for myself i filmed it and watched it
and then i went back and i'm like
we both did really good here but you did
did you do it differently
i didn't do it differently because i was
like if you were just copying him they
said it's not the same yeah yeah um
so i just thought so much differently
but i had different you know like it
wasn't a mimicked performance wasn't
rehearsed
and i remember thinking
[ __ ] i can i can do this i actually
really like that as a piece of advice
for training yourself as an actor is
trying roles that you've already seen
and attempting them like one of my
favorite performances in anything ever
have you seen hereditary
oh god yes actually i think tony
collette yeah in that movie
is
incredible like just an oscar-worthy
performance and it sucks like that's
like the ultimate like horror doesn't
get nominated like if she didn't horror
doesn't get nominated but that is a
thing that like god if i would have
tried it i think you could see a million
actors or actresses try to do what tony
collette did in hereditary in terms of
the grief and all do it very differently
and something about the way she does it
is not orthodox she didn't read any
notes nobody like it's so unusual but
it's so visceral in a way that's like
how would i do that how would other
actors do that that's the thing about
that movie right it's uh
it's
it was the first time
but
when you talk about hereditary too long
but okay
let's go
it was the first time in
20 years of watching horror movies
where i couldn't sleep yeah i have to
sit here yeah can i watch my wife
doesn't watch she hates horrible i love
hara do i have to watch them by myself
my daughter's getting there she's a lot
she's still too young yeah but
eventually she'll she'll watch them with
me but
so i had to watch hereditary alone like
at one in the morning
and when it was over i'm like
i'm just gonna wait till the sun comes
up it is like something now
oh man
again we could talk about hereditary
that
the her on the wall that i think
the from the beginning of the parents
being like you have to go to this party
to her tony collect crying on the floor
is the best short film ever made
it's awful it's horrendous it's actually
the accidents in the middle there right
yeah just and and even how alex wolf
he's sitting there in the car and he's
and the way he says are you okay he like
stumbles out of his mouth and he
slightly looks in the rearview mirror
but then doesn't and it just [ __ ]
goes to bed
oh my god it's so good like oh that's
really good and the acting is so
top-notch yeah there's this stuff like
that that sometimes makes me mad like
into the spite of us i think is such a
good movie that i'm like if i ever make
anything as good as even a single frame
of this like [ __ ] hell
here
i think that a lot i think that a lot
i'll watch a movie
just as an actor and i'll just watch it
and go oh i want to be able to do that
you did that yeah
i like that no i want to be able to do
that yeah i mean yeah but like they did
it like oh yeah [ __ ] you did that how
god damn it how did you get to that
place and you gotta figure it out also i
really do i felt that way about
everything everywhere all at once as
well did you see that
i haven't seen it yet i was gonna go
with the whole cast of the show but i
couldn't yeah i very much they all loved
it that's one of those things that like
it's so good that it seems like it
shouldn't have been made it's like a
wow how did studio interference not
prevent you from nailing the execution
of this and selling the exact point that
you wanted that expertly like it's it's
yeah it's just one of those
i worked with michelle yo and she's
wonderful she's incredible too she's so
so personal yeah i'm sure she's amazing
in that she's very very good in it and
everything else i love her um in any
case we could just enthuse about things
we like watching probably for several
hours but i promise i would not keep you
too late so i won't uh where can people
find you
oh just on uh on twitter i was gonna say
i'm waiting for for the question like so
what's coming up and i'm like well
there's nda and then there's gender well
i was gonna ask that too
that's the next question just twitter
i'm not much of an instagram person but
i do
i do have an account but uh it's mostly
twitter what is the twitter account it's
just my name elias two places i'll leave
a link in the description um and
anything that you would like to promote
other than nda nda and aaa
oh man i mean blood of zeus we just
finished season two
but it's being animated now
and then that game i'm doing with [ __ ]
is really good and that came
in that game sounds like a lot of nda
soon all right
i can't wait to see nda and play nda no
looking forward to it
um thank you for joining me thanks
everybody for watching see you next time
[Music]
you